thank you David it's my pleasure to be
here I would like to begin by thanking
your van cot and the organizers of this
institute so I wrote a couple of things
on the boards to prepare for the
lectures so let's first take a look at
the notation that I will be using
standard notation XY a pair of discrete
random variables with a joint
distribution but the conditional entropy
the mutual information between x and y
and vector forms this X to the N it will
denote a vector of length n so these are
two vectors jointly distributed with
some joint distribution the conditional
entropy the mutual information but here
these are not definitions these are the
chain rules the conditional entropy can
be written can be written as the sum of
conditional entropies and the mutual
information can be written is the sum of
mutual informations normally i okay put
the conditioning here let's put it there
if the U is are independent the
conditioning here can be removed and
this can be put in conjunction with Y
and but this form is whether the un's
the UI's are independent or not this is
always true the UI of the excited yes
this is the X pi minus 1 and X I minus 1
is X 1 X I minus 1 okay so it's Wu this
away and I would like to for those who
are impatient I would like to put up
here 2 main theorem and everything is
really going to be a consequence of this
one so there are two theorems one I call
source polarization source polarization
so it all boils down to I mean if you
were to explain this to somebody let's
say a mathematician who doesn't really
have any background in information
theory and it's not really interested in
where it came from how would you get his
or her attention so you definitely would
want to write in a compact form what
this thing is about so I try to make
exactly that in here suppose we have a
random variable X this is going to be a
source random variable we will think of
it as a reference random variable
representing a discrete memoryless
source I don't want to be too general
here I will assume the source is a
binary source so as simple as it can be
and then we will have a sequence of
outputs from this source
iid meaning that the source is
memoryless and they will all have the
same distribution as X it is great map
on the source a binary member the source
these are Bernoulli random variables
therefore they take the values 0 and 1
then I what we will do is we will pick a
black tank and it will be a power of two
in a power of two and we will define a
new random vector a transformed random
vector u n of length and again so this
by vectors are raw vectors this is a
matrix capital n times capital n so this
one is also a row vector this matrix
here is the chronicle power of that one
everything is in GF 2 ma true malta
plication z-- and additions so what is
the chronicle power maybe we should also
illustrate that here so f is already p
and defined like this it's very small I
exercise so for n equal to 2 my vector
is going to be u 1 u 2 mult
which will be given by X 1 X 2 x 1 0 1 1
so this is going to be X 1 plus X 2 and
extra so this is addition modulo 2
sometimes I put a circle around it we
indicated that's it for n equal to 2 for
n equal to 4 4 is equal to 2 to the true
so small n is equal to 2 I will be
computing u 1 u 3 u 3 u 4
x1 x2 x3 x4 and here ii chronicle power
of f so how is it defined in general
it's defined like this the end chronicle
power is defined as f
so you it is defined this this have - 1
Chronicle product F and the chronicle
product off and this one is simply if a
minus 1 if M minus 1 is 0 here if have
minus 1 what is the definition of the
Kronecker product so you can take any
two matrices and the chronicle product
is simply a 1 1 times B a 1 2 times B
and so on ok so it each element of this
one is multiplying the entire matrix B
is it clear okay so this one cleared
then
so this matrix here is going to be
capital n times kept them and in size so
what we have is we had a random vector X
10 and it had iid components we passed
it through a transformation to obtain
this view n this transformation here is
a one-to-one transformation it is an
inverse so the inverse of this matrix is
itself you can verify take this matrix
and multiply it with itself you get the
identity the inverse of the nth
chronicle power is itself again these
are simple to verify so we have a
one-to-one transformation okay so why
did we do this okay so now in the
background intuitive background what I
want to do is I want to compress this
vector source coding but that I find
difficult instead I'm going to be to
source coding on this one UN alright it
will be much easier to the source coding
on this because of this statement here
so you take any delta fix it fix it as a
small number positive this ratio here
what is it but these are the conditional
entropy terms
there are n of these ones okay so I
ranges from one to n so there are n such
terms so we are looking at the fraction
of terms for which the conditional
entropy lies between Delta and 1 minus
Delta take Delta is something like 1% so
this range is a pretty wide range
compared to you know the interval 0 0 1
so if this is 0 this is 1 and this is
Delta and 1 minus Delta so anything that
lies in this range I include I count it
in here one would expect this fraction
to be large because it occupies almost
all of the interval here but that's not
the case so in telemedicine goes to
infinity for any fixed at that fraction
is 0 okay it's close to 0 so there is
almost nothing in this interval for in a
Delta no matter how small it is this is
called source polarization the entropy
is polarized to the extremes so they
since they are not here in this interval
they must be either here or there
why should they be in here the entropy
of a binary random variable is upper
bounded by one okay so this number is
definitely less than or equal to one
well althoguh rhythms are two base true
and we are considering the binary
alphabet
so this thing is also a binary vector so
all the entropies are either near zero
almost all of them or near one
in fact this falls not only with fixed
Delta but you may let that become small
its relate and go to infinity you can
let Delta also become small like this
this is roughly it's difficult to
understand what this thing is so it's
just a little less precise way of
writing it I can roughly speaking I can
let that go to zero exponentially in the
square root of the block length and this
statement is still true I'm not going to
give the proof of this one that's we
will leave it to the second lecture or
the third lecture but I didn't want to
make sure is that we understand the
statement here and see how it can be
useful for coding so first of all do we
have any questions about this statement
here it's true the meaning of it
clear okay so to enter peers are
polarizing they are moving to the
extremes okay so that's done I'll just
question to the question of whether it
would be any easier to do source coding
directly on um on UN rather than
directly on X and okay so then the idea
is I will describe this but let me move
on if you like to show a colored part of
the same result for channel coding so
there is just one one more thing which I
would like to add here before moving to
channel coding part so there is a
corollary to this one if you if you
believe this one the corollary says the
following the fraction of coordinates
for which the conditional entropy is
between Delta and 1 minus Delta is basic
to 0 there is nothing in here
so which fraction should be inter and
which fraction should be in here but the
total the total entropy is fixed
so let's prove the correlative before
moving on by not writing on the stuff
behind your whiteboard no I'm not going
to do that that would come off your
salary okay don't worry about that okay
so let's let's do some further analysis
on this so we have okay H the entropy in
the Specter you because we have a
one-to-one transformation is the same as
the entropy in X because the
transformation is one-to-one
this one we are assuming that we have a
memoir less source x1x2 they're all iíd
hence the entropy in the joint ensemble
is simply to sum of the entropies in the
individual coordinates and each
coordinate is distributed the same way
as X hence the total entropy is n times
HX okay so this is entropy conservation
it is entropy conservation by the chain
rule we also have the following
okay so this is the change rule
if we put these two together we can
write this therefore what I know is the
sum of these terms is equal to n times
the original entropy and we concrete the
following thing
therefore I mean given that almost all
of them are either near zero or near one
I'm talking about these terms can we
reach this conclusion that was near one
that was near one should be roughly if
there should be some qualifications here
like that weird one okay so at the
number of them or maybe not
not even this one okay so those near one
if you take Delta small enough then it's
fair to say that the entropy terms that
are near one the fraction of them is
approximately equal to H of X because
there is nothing in here and those that
are in here the total entropy you can
accumulate by summing these ones we said
plus delta x and right to sum of the
entropies here can it must be delta x n
there is a negligible fraction of
entropy terms in here so don't even
count them so this much entropy has to
be accounted for
is to be accounted for almost almost all
of it must be due to the terms that are
deciding in here okay so that's what
this one is saying okay so - okay so
they'd say all right that's something
which we will discuss okay that's that's
definitely an important point okay but
all I can say is we can compute where
they have large entropy in order and
time portal and context where n is the
size of the transform so we have an
efficient algorithm for computing it but
we don't really have a formula that you
can just write down and find out which
coordinates are the high entropy
coordinates okay so I know well if you
like that stand on this subject and see
how we can use this one to to do source
coding I will show it I will shove it
okay
I want to purposefully avoid such
questions because I want to show what
you can do if it is true okay otherwise
otherwise you know we get lost okay so I
want to show you the final result and if
you find it interesting you would you've
read the proof anyway somewhere okay you
always have that option but before you
leave I have limited amount of time I
want to make sure that you understand
you know what the main theorem is okay
so how can we use this for source coding
okay so application to source coding
so suppose you know I have computed
Taurus coordinates
it's called them H these are the
coordinates right such that entropy is
is large
it's be a little imprecise okay these
are the coordinates the high entropy
coordinates where the conditional
entropy is approximately equal to one
okay so what we know is the the number
of such elements is approximately equal
to ten times the entropy of the original
source okay so this is a summary of
everything that I have said alright so
how can we do source coding so we have
computed this set okay somebody asked is
it easy to compute the set no it's not
that easy but suppose we have computed
that we have it so we will do the source
coding as follows
it's first to have a picture to explain
exactly what I mean by source coding but
there will be you know this extent
coming from the source we are going to
transform it to obtain UN okay
and there will be a source encoder here
a polar source encoder if you will this
is going to send out a number of bits
okay so in fact let me write exactly
what it will send out it will send out
these bits what is that this u sub H
it's this is the subject of the new
vector consisting of coordinates in the
high entropy set okay so and then there
will be a decoder here which is going to
first reconstruct the view vector and
since it's a one-to-one transformation
it will apply the inverse which is this
to obtain an estimate of the original
source okay so this is the structure to
architecture for the source code that we
want to use
so to make it absolutely clear let's say
n is equal to 8 let's take a small
number and let's suppose the high
entropy set consists of the coordinates
3 5
seven eight okay maybe four six the high
entropy set is usually no it just the
other way around
usually the small coordinates they say
one two one two three and five okay
suppose that this is the case that I
have computed high entropy set these are
the high entropy indices so the way the
proposed source coding algorithm will
work is as follows okay so for each i
for i from 1 to n to the following if y
belongs to the high entropy set
okay high-end preppy set the entropy is
approximately equal to one sent you sub
I this is a great age realization so I
have here such in quarter this is going
to be a ton of course not with I that
with the random vector but with the
realization or the and the vector okay
so a small case these are the capital
case letters indicate the random
variables but for an operational system
like this if you like this replace all
of these things with small case letters
so that we have
so everybody the exes and the use here
are specific realizations so the encoder
is called with a specific inputs now we
look at the first coordinate if the
first coordinate is a high entropy
coordinate it is in this case we sent
you sub I is is without it is in a
change okay it is sent over here so u1
is going to be sent out by the encoder
because one is a high entropy coordinate
yes if it is not a high entropy
coordinate
okay maybe I should change this
statement a little bit because let's
redefine this page erased it already but
let me define it as mothers it's the set
of coordinates such that H of UI
conditional on the past is greater than
Delta okay so not 1 minus Delta but
Delta why did I do this because I also
want to send in the clear all
coordinates with entropy is greater than
Delta Delta may be small okay so Delta
may be for example 1/2 so if I don't
sent these coordinates for the decoder
it will be hard to guess them correct by
changing the definition problem 1 minus
Delta 2 Delta 2 Delta I have not really
increased the cardinality of the set
much because you see the cardinality
here is roughly n times HX but the same
thing is true also for this one ok
because the fraction that lies in here
is almost 0 so for in a high entropy
coordinate we will send it as it is as
what we will do we will skip it
ok and then we will continue so this is
the loop
so in this case what I would be sending
out would be gue 1 u 2 u 2 u 3 & u 5
that's all so I'm sending four bits for
coordinates of the computed new vector
and now it's the decoders task to
estimate the entire vector the missing
coordinates or the view vector will it
be able to do so okay so the coordinates
that are missing from here are the ones
for which the conditional entropy is
less than Delta so if it were 0 if the
condition of the entropy were 0 what
would it mean it would mean that you
know that the UI would be a function of
the previous use having it less than
Delta is something close to being
deterministic all of this needs to be
justified of course okay so that's the
detail of the proof I which I don't
intend to give today okay so those
coordinates which I skipped over are the
log entropy coordinates for which
this conditional entropy is less than
Delta and I'm hoping that the decoder
will not have much difficulty in
reconstructing the missing coordinates
here okay so alright so one task which
we need to tackle later on is estimate
the probability of decoding error here
okay so based on the assumption that the
missing coordinates have conditional
entropy is less than Delta what will be
the probability of error in the
reconstruction I'll give you the answer
the probability of error is less than
true to the minus square root of n
provided that provided that there is
nothing provide so we are yeah as it is
you know we can prove this one we are
sending enough coordinates I was going
to say provided that we are sending date
data at a rate above the entropy of the
source but we are already doing it okay
because we are sending all the high
entropy coordinates so the rate of
communication in here is above the
entropy of the source the decoder we
will show later on I will be able to
reconstruct you with a probability of
error that cost zero exponentially in
the square root of the block length but
this is something that needs to be
proven
calculation to understand this step age
that is not any conjectures like you
said it seems like obvious at age it is
it is not an interval okay so it was
like a chaotic set with many holes in it
what do you mean by binary
representation to set the set is an
irregular said it is not like all the
indices from 1 to some number and then
omit the rest it will be it will have
many holes in it ok like four is missing
in here for a large end there it will
have it will show almost no structure
okay except most of the small numbers
are going to be in the entropy set and
large numbers will be outside it so
after we reconstruct this the rest is
easy
so by the probability of error of course
I mean that this estimate is not equal
to the original input ok so this is the
source coding algorithm so the the or
case
yeah one more thing which I wanted to
say how many bits are we sending in here
we are sending as many bits here is the
cardinality of this set
what is the Cardinals you have to set
it's approximately equal to n times Ajax
yes we have compressed the source to its
entropy limit okay so if the only thing
which remains is to prove this one which
we will do later on so this completes
the part about what I want to do today
about source polarization but before I
move on to the channel polarization part
maybe I should I should pause and if you
have any questions please
that statement also holds with betta
exactly equal to 1/2 yes for any for any
Delta you mean alright this one okay no
all right but this is this is true
arctic to right done okay so this is an
approximation for any beta strictly less
than 1/2 the statement is true it is not
true if beta is equal to 1/2 but ok so
this approximation is a shorthand for
writing all of this ok and you're using
that green statement for that for video
right yes this is also ok
you only need exponential because you do
Union bound it's only multiplying n
terms to it right so yeah this is your
PI but any positive beta would give the
conclusion because your Union bound is
going to or any beta would I can put in
here any beta
I mean okay so two Delta there there is
also a delta okay so that's the there is
also at this data in here I would want
to make this Delta shrink to zero okay I
can only let this shrink to zero
at that rate with beta less than a half
okay and this data shows up in the Union
bonds here so if you want to be precise
replace this called my square root ends
with the statement here okay with this
one
so it's David indicated final results
it's just a little one little step ahead
you know all you need to do is find a
bound on the probability of error in
estimating this from its past assuming
that it is correct under the assumption
that this entropy is less than Delta
okay if you have reconstructed the
sequence up to I indexed I correct the
condition of probability of making an
error at the eighth step what you need
to do is give it give a bound on the
probability of error at the ice step
under the assumption that this entropy
is smooth okay so that's that's
something really minor but we will get
to it okay so the main idea let's
summarize it then we had this original
source we transformed it into a new
source this must memorize this is not on
good memories but it is polarized the
conditional entropies are either near
zero or near one okay so that gives
suggests this source coding algorithm
all I need to do is send the coordinates
which cannot be estimated by the decoder
they are high entropy coordinates they
have entropy close to one in fact even
if they had entropy let's say point
seven to five or it would be too risky
to not send them it is not only that
they have so if they have entropy is
close to saturation almost one okay so
if they are purely random the pure
randomness ensures that we are not by
sending them we are also not losing much
from efficiency because they are
incompressible the bits that we sent
already have conditional entry
be equal to one so by sending them
without an according director we are not
losing any efficiency okay so they are
already saturated in terms of entropy
okay so it's clear what polarization
does here okay so what questions remain
here there are there is the proof of
this statement okay within the stronger
form and then the proof of this
statement so it's just modular it is
alright this is source polarization okay
now I want to turn to this chain of
polarization there is a counterpart of
the source polarization theorem
so now instead of a single random
variable we have a pair of random
variables x and y so here we think of X
is the input to it nevertheless Channel
X W and Y so this channel here W it is
part of the conditioned probability
assignment the channel input has a
probability distribution that you can
select arbitrarily but the conditional
probability of the channel output given
the input is fixed that we call W
channel this is a this is going to be a
discrete memoryless channel okay and so
the conditional probability of a vector
of channel outputs will have a product
form once again to make the presentation
simple I will assume that input here
comes from a binary alphabet the
alphabet here is 0 1 this is the general
input alphabet the general output
alphabet this may be arbitrary it may
even be continuous like a binary input
editing Gaussian noise channel so we
don't put any restrictions whatsoever on
the output except my notation would have
to change and I would have to use some
densities and so on so let's assume to
be to be precise that the output in this
presentation is also discrete ok you may
assume even that this is a binary
symmetric channel if you wish so let's
begin reading this statement we have a
reference ensemble then X and a general
input and the channel output this is a
vector ensemble of iid pairs each
element of the vector I is identically
distributed as the XY here
so we are not discussing channel coding
at the moment okay so we are just as in
here at some point I will refer to a
channel coding algorithm but we are not
there yet so don't think of this is a
court rather think of it as a memory
less ensemble a product for an ensemble
on the channel input what we do here is
similar I instead of instead of this X
and we think of that is the input to a
bigger channel they need to have a
picture here
we should make it clear
so it is like this we have and copies of
the channel this is how I think about it
there are n independent copies of the
channel this is the input ensemble and
they are to turn sample what we do here
is we apply a transformation
then we have another ensemble here if
you are sample so since this
transformation is identical the inverse
is the same as the transformation the
order of things you can really think
either going this way or that way so
that's the you hear U is defined as X
multiplied by this transformation so
this statement the claim here is the
following for any fixed Delta greater
than 0 mutual information from UI
through the entire output and the past
inputs here lying between Delta and 1
minus Delta divided by n so this is a
fraction here that fraction goes to 0 as
n goes to infinity ok so this needs to
be interpreted careful yes you need to
say u equals x staff or x equals UF
okay so you see X is the output from you
all right sorry it's kind of misleading
but all right we have this one since if
I know universe
you want the causal way of looking at
but I didn't test I didn't want to look
at this as the input to that transform
to be to be honest yes yes it's the way
I want to look at it so you really need
this yes I mean this yes yes oh that's a
bit strange right because I thought you
is the here the primary on sample is the
X on sample okay so think of this what
did I do in here X was the source
ensemble okay I had no observations size
information if you like right and so I
transformed this into a you ensemble
that's exactly the same thing that I
want to do it here but in applying
channel coding Gunter's able to reverse
this I will take this as the input and I
will generate the XS okay sorry this is
the way it is I didn't mean it yes this
this example is defined I define a new
one sample to you ensemble okay so what
is the meaning of this what is the
operational meaning of these terms over
here
so the first term the u1 given all the
all the outputs here this is why and
okay so
so this is the this is a mutual
information this is the a cheaper rate
on a channel whose input is U 1 and
whose output is y n there is an
effective binary input channel think of
the binary input channel with u1 is the
input and Y and is the output
so these terms in thinking about that
channel
these are acting as interference okay so
you have you to through UN which are
random variables I don't I want to erase
the errors here so there is that was for
interpretation but
okay so I have I have a channel here
okay with input u 1 and with all these
things as the outputs I know there is a
non sample here okay so a well defined
ensemble a joint probability
distribution on xn and yn I'm keeping
that distribution there is also a Joint
Distribution look it is like this UN
okay now you can think in the other
direction should David remember this
channel and yn you seem probable that
there is no causality okay so a joint
distribution you see whether I begin
with access and define this ensemble in
terms of the exon sample or change the
order it doesn't matter okay so for
channel coding purposes it's more
natural to think in this direction of
course but the UN has been defined
relative to the X and ensemble okay in
if this transformation was not itself
inverse I would have written here a
different equation of course I would
have written I would have written UN as
X and
the inverse like this shirt anyway right
maybe I should okay because in applying
coding I will begin with this one and I
will generate the code word using this
equation okay so let me start again
I am given a difference on sample okay I
want to keep this fixed so I'm going to
be playing around with this so this is
basically my choice we could have used
here different transforms we could have
used here different transforms and this
is not the only transport for which this
statement is true in fact for in a
random transform you will have this
statement in a stronger form much
stronger form the main point about this
transformation is it's easy to compute
the complexity will show up at some
point so we can do the computation here
in n log n time and the decoding also in
n log n time okay so that's let's look
over here
so there is this first channel with
input u 1 and R 2 consisting of all Y
ends supposing that you decode this
correctly you gain access to another bit
channel the second bit channel which has
disk this capacity
supposing that you have decoded you and
correct now you again access to this
channel you to the mutual information
from you to to all the channel outputs
conditional on knowledge of you one and
this goes on and on so we generate these
terms in here let me put a condition of
conditioning in here for for xiii t
bandar the one half the excise the you
eyes are also done on the house one
can't remove the conditioning because of
independence but not in general so
anyway what we are counting in here are
exact the channels whose capacities are
near one and this corollary here is the
counterpart of the entropy corollary so
it says the channels for which the
capacity is near 1 is approximately
equal to 10 times the capacity of the
original channel
not exactly the capacity but mutual
information ok so here I'm really trying
to be more general than in the following
sense I'm not assuming that this
distribution is Bernoulli 1/2 ok so when
you compute to transform here this one
the elements of this transform are not
by ID 2 X the elements of X are IID but
the elements of you are not IIT hence we
cannot remove this ok so if the user if
the you is are independent it's okay to
remove this conditioning but otherwise
you have to keep this in here it is like
site information given to you by perhaps
a helpful
or some somebody and the meaning of this
in channel coding terms is this is the a
chaebol rate on a channel in which you
are coding this input UI all previous
inputs are given through to the decoder
correctly and the succeeding inputs are
treated as interference as noise so
that's the operational meaning of this
one this is the a chaebol rate on a
channel with input UI what is available
to the decoder is this observation here
Plus knowledge of these ones
but these ones are treated as random
noise is pure noise you have not yet
come to that so the statement is similar
to this statement okay so you either
have almost perfect channels whose
capacities are near one for channels
whose capacity is near zero so if you
are going to do a chain of coding what
you do is clear you use only the
coordinates for which the mutual
information here is near one so you
select those coordinates for which this
information is near one and you send
your data encoded or through them what
do you do for the remaining ones when
the capacity is near zero so what you do
is you fix them you set for example the
mutual information they'd say this one
is near zero what we do is we fix this
input to zero you try let's say the
mutual information is also near zero we
fix that one to zero to I is a is an
index for which the mutual information
is near one we want to use this channel
so here we select this from a Bernoulli
distribution we selected from some
distribution okay so if I assume that
these are all banner their health let's
assume that to make it simpler say these
are all Bernoulli a half then this
transformation here this transformation
will generate another half ìit use
advice here so you want to apply coding
kunti's and you can select it also is
Bernoulli 1/2 in freezing some
coordinates you can select two
value of those coordinates from this
distribution and fix it in other words
you don't have to set them equal to zero
all the time you may select them at
random and freeze them by a random
choice okay sorry
so what you really want to ensure is the
following that probabilities that you
use in coding and you are operating on
the inputs you they should generate the
same reference distribution over here
okay if these are not bad knowing
they're half the choice of the
distribution on these coordinates is a
lot more complicated of course okay
sometimes we want to apply an input
distribution on the channels which is
not the uniform distribution you can do
that through the use of this one but
conditional probabilities of each reaiiy
conditioned on the past you have to
select the coordinate accordingly okay
not from the uniform distribution well
anyway I think I have come to the end of
my time so I will stop here I hope I
have been able to explain to the main
theorems so next time I will talk about
the plush the details etc so I stopped
you think
this hour is there any questions here
the question there is no assumption that
it is a distribution random variable
here is a is a zero one random variable
there is no an assumption on this one
you mean if this were uniform
distribution then you know that's not
really a very interesting case but let's
see if anything in here is wrong this
entropy this entropy would be one in
that case okay this would be one so and
in that case there is no need to do any
compression these things are already
saturated they have entropy one and the
UN here it's also going to have the same
distribution so you will basically be
sending all the use ok sending all the
years is equivalent to sending all the
XS immediate polarization you don't
really need to go through this you
simply Sunday access director it's
better yes any for in a finite and but
your question was really whether this
holds for that case it it holds yes
because these entropy is r1 okay in the
case that you are referring to the large
end
what is known about how fast this goes
to their [ __ ] says it already this
already says how fast it goes to zero
this part here yet this part says okay
so how fast does it go to zero this one
okay I see okay there are two turbos
there there is some work on it okay yes
so what is in other words this cost the
zero but how fast does it go to zero
okay so the the fraction that remains in
here that's what I am indicating here
that goes to zero as this number here
okay
if you want that you have traction to be
less than say a delta it make the whole
thing happen in this yeah maybe you want
to call it silver but it kind of come it
seems it's okay to merge those because
you will give up on all those things in
the middle anyway sorry oh there is not
exponentially small yeah that's it so
maybe you want to call that epsilon this
this question comes up when you deal
with gap to capacity type of issues okay
so if they're skating business and so on
I haven't really looked at that careful
there but there are some papers by
really gable banker banker correspondent
and so there's a lot of about a great
number of papers on the subject so okay
so that's the gap to capacity business
so a quick question just a little
clarification so do you want these
exercise to be exactly I definitely what
happened there is no such assumption in
the way this theorem is stated in it is
correct as it is written the excise are
IID but they are not ban or they have
these are if these are not Bernoulli a
half
these are not even independent
if they are been newly evolved then
these are also been in their house they
are and these are well are you
considering if we are not conditioning
on yn8 so if these are if you are just
considering the marginal distribution of
this one the marginal distribution of
this one is iid banner the Bernoulli 1/2
if xn is iid been away 1/2 because this
is a one-to-one transformation of the
space almost the same way as source
polarization some of these numbers are
big close to 1 which correspond to
having almost perfect yes but you are
not sending information by using each
and every one of them so these are I
understand your question so they say
these are let's say binary symmetric
channel switch capacity 1/2 okay so you
can only send it rate 1/2 so you'll be
sending information data in n over 2
coordinates over here okay
in approximately n over 2 of these
coordinates the remaining ones are going
to be frozen and the decoders will know
how they they have been frozen in order
to make this you know the proof work in
the analysis tractable what you do is
you do a performance analysis random
choices for the freezing pattern okay
you see what I mean what does it kurup's
to X I yes the channel corrupts the
exercise but this is a virtual channel
ok so the channels that you see here
these are synthetic channels these are
not the original channels these are
synthesized okay
so it is like these are our raw material
if you like they have a total capacity
equal to n times the capacity of each
what we do is we combine the capacities
of this and then slice them apart in
such a way that the synthetic channels
namely these ones they either get very
small capacity or full capacity okay so
you combine them and then you cut them
into small pieces again but you do it in
such a way that the entropy the mutual
information is redistributed in an
uneven fashion in is unequal fashion as
possible some of them get nothing and
the rest get you know as much as one can
have close to one bit of capacity you
cannot have more than one bit because
the inputs are 0 1 valued okay so this
is not difficult to do in a channel
coding scheme effectively does exactly
the same thing so there is no secret
about this transformation you put in
here
in a randomly chosen transport with
probability close to one it is going to
achieve this result and in fact it will
achieve it in a much stronger fashion in
the sense that you say there will be no
gaps that question of how to compute you
know high entropy set or the perfect
channel set that entirely vanishes okay
so it is much stronger polarization a
random linear code will do exactly that
okay now what this one does I didn't
have any chance to talk about that today
the reason why we use this transform in
here is because this is a recursive
transform so it makes encoding and
decoding easy Porter's n log n ok so and
at the same time
it achieves a probability of error
similar to this the numbers that you see
here 2 to the minus square root n it's
the probability of error it is not as
good as a random linear code because the
random linear code can achieve a
probability of error the number here is
proportional to n in the exponent ok so
this is the in fact we are losing
something but this is good enough in
some sense you still have some
exponential rate of decay of probability
of error so this doesn't have an error
floor for example ok it is not optimal
but it is more complexed both encoding
and decoding
okay good all right so we look forward
to a part two well thank you thank you
thank you thank you